hello everybody hope they are good let's
catch up with bitcoin's price action if
you remember from yesterday's video we
made this production okay that's the
yellow uh lines okay and if you remember
well it was based on let's go into the
four or something you're gonna see it
better it was based on that we were in
this range for quite some time here we
saw a deviation okay and now we're
expecting price to break to the downside
okay here you can see that it broke down
then you see here that we had this uh
trend line that I was telling yesterday
that there is always a lot of liquidity
below this trend line because it's full
of stop losses from people longing at
supporting the train line so price will
eventually take that liquidity okay
so our position was based on that also
if you notice here this white line here
that's the range lows and if we go back
into the one hour time frame you can see
how yesterday they didn't really come to
fill this liquidity pool over here
and it got rejected at the range flows
okay so uh even even actually even
tested resistance so you have here some
opportunities to enter a short okay then
another short opportunities here when
you lose the trailer and test the
resistance you can see there clearly
okay how it happens uh that could be a
nice scalp now we're still expecting
Bitcoin to come lower
okay because if you've seen the
thumbnail that I posted today we're
gonna go to Hard Rock in a minute okay
is so with a lot of liquidity
in this Zone over here okay that's
basically between 28 800 and 28 700 okay
so in this one here there is a lot of
liquidity and we're expecting Bitcoin to
come lower now today's Friday you know
what I usually think about the weekends
don't expect much more vendor in the
weekend because there is not much
liquidity the stock market Forex they
are closed institutional Traders they're
enjoying the their weekends with their
families so don't expect much liquidity
all right
um therefore not much movement so the
question is are you gonna see today in
the New York City that's going to start
in a couple of hours are you gonna see
the move to the downside or are they
gonna you know hold in this Zone
and maybe we see this target getting hit
next week uh that's the question that
you have to ask yourself
um I'm gonna I'm gonna remove this
projection because I want to talk more
in detail about today's price action
here you can see that we are developing
a potential double deformation okay
that's your second drop here and it
would confirm if you can break above the
one hour 50ma so if you see something
like this you know enter the national
leg up and then it retraces and we are
holding support at the 1 hour 50ma then
that's the moment that you say okay that
Target of 28 800 28 700
it'll probably won't happen today it
probably happened next week
okay so you have to know the
invalidation and what you want to see in
the candles in order to take your trades
and execute them okay so uh that's what
I think I'm still favoring lower prices
this one is my target okay
Bo of course you know if today we form
this information and we stay above the
150 main then you know time to close the
chart and come back next week for that
Target okay that's what I think then if
we lose
this Support over here
okay if you notice in the chart there is
no much more support
okay you have maybe this Zone over here
that's the 29 000 but I mean being so
close to it the most likely is that you
start to fall you know consolidate
continue dropping and again they're
gonna reach your target of 20 800. so
um that's pretty much everything you
have here this support break the support
however as your target getting hit I
think or
foreign
hold here and then this projection gets
invalidated for today and it will
probably happen
next week okay uh that's what I see into
this price action so
um not very favoring to trade this okay
if you are not in a position at the
moment then your chance is to
if you see Bitcoin using the support
then that could be a quick scalp okay
towards the sun is not much movement
maybe it's 1.5 percent I think uh yeah
around one to five percent so that's
only a small scalp or if you say Bitcoin
form in this double information are
holding above the 150 ma then uh could
you take along here
I mean
what are you expecting okay you're gonna
have probably a resistance here again
right here they're gonna see another
resistance so I don't think that's a
Zone to make business okay at least for
me because you have here too many
resistance okay you have the 150 May
then you have here this train line and
you also have the range lows so no as
shown here to look for Longs just yet
that's what I think okay
um of course no Financial advice
you guys do uh what you think boo
um you ultimately
um favorite
this one over here
get in hit okay now the question is is
you're gonna get hit today or next week
uh that's pretty much everything that I
think now if you go into the index
I think warning you for quite some time
the dollar Index was looking good in my
opinion okay if you notice here you had
let's go start in the daily time frame
you have this support here one
two okay the three tops pattern is
basically three tabs to our support Auto
resistance and then
a reversal okay usually the third type
comes with a deviation so that's what I
was telling you that you know it
wouldn't surprise me if we see a
deviation below 100 because that would
also be quite a psychological play you
know to fall below 100 if you're in 99
you're in two days it's not three so
then Traders are gonna favor shorts and
click which is quite psychological now
do so that deviation
now if you're going to the forward time
frame
we can see here how Bitcoin you mean
deviated Tesla support here then filled
this Gap here this uh white box over
there you can see how I filled it hang
on I have retraced it okay
then you go on the retrace and now it's
pumping again so
um as long as in my opinion the dollar
Index is above this white line then I
think that we are good okay in fact if
you notice he even hit pretty much your
target whatever was 100 to 80 and it
went to 100 sorry 101 180 and I'm going
to
101.65 so uh pretty much done okay
um but anyways above this white line
then it has room to continue going high
of course it has room to go to 103 104
105 okay now if you lose this this white
line over there
then it's gonna look good for Bitcoin
because the dollar Index you know has
room to fall for example once when I'm
releasing so quickly there
97 okay if you lose this white line
then the dollar Index is going to
continue going low and it's going to go
to 97. that last that's when between
continue going higher
okay but seeing how the chart is looking
at the moment that we are above support
I can only favor the idea that the
dollar Index is looking pretty good to
continue going higher okay that's what I
think I know for example some of you
might draw a trend line maybe I don't
know something like this so maybe you're
expecting the dollar Index to hit the
trailer again that's
102.60 I'm good with that okay if that
happens I'm happy because you know I
mean that would be a nice pump another
index that we're anticipating so uh
that's what I think about Bitcoin this I
think Bitcoin should go to 20
28.8 28.7 either today or the next week
and the dollar Index at the moment is
looking like we could favor higher
prices in the large index okay now if
you go into the SMP
I want to have a look because I didn't
have a look for some days now to be
honest uh consolidating
here are the highs
um let me go into the four hour time
frame
it's not looking it's not looking
bearish to be honest it's not looking
either bearish or bullies in my opinion
here okay remember that is to look for
deviations in these little lines okay
something like this
okay because we have a gap here
this blue box that's a gap that within
that price should go to okay so uh do
you have the idea of the deviation but
for now is it's not confirming
navigation at all
and if it continues going higher then
you have here the next one would you
could see a deviation okay uh that's
what I think about the SMP and if we go
for example and check Euro versus the
dollar this should be dumping yep so
let's go into the four hour time frame
okay it's recovering now I think because
the
yeah there you go
so because this red candle
then you got here Euro
recovering some zones over here okay to
the upside now
how much or how low
actually I thought I'm pretty sure that
zombies I got one we were talking about
the euro versus I'm pretty sure
that this was or Target uh I don't
remember because I removed the drawings
okay but I'm pretty sure that that was
for Target here this security pool over
here
um to be honest here I hit it and then
it bounced what a shame that I missed
this trade I didn't pay much attention
to this chart because I was looking at
Bitcoin but that was a nice setup to be
honest
um let's see what it does of course it
can retrace more zones to the upside
like these two candles for example they
are quite uh large red candles you know
to mirror imbalances in the chart so uh
why not you don't might now hit these
zones but to the downside
I don't really see
many more targets okay uh we could argue
that this liquidity will be another
Target okay but
uh why not maybe now the Euro can
continue bouncing a bit maybe to 111
before dropping low okay something like
that uh why not that would be quite
you know stopping everybody out don't
you think
this retrace then domes another very
aggressive literally so far
and then Adam so uh that could fit with
a narrative to be honest okay uh that's
so far what I think about the euro
versus the dollar
um let's have a look now a high block
capital for Bitcoin why don't have low
Capital 12 first time frame another
interesting I don't see any bright
yellow bar so I'm gonna skip this chart
let's go to the seven days time frame
um I'm gonna show you the song that I'm
talking about in this video okay you got
here 28 800 28 700 a lot of liquidity
okay
that's what we are targeting the area
the more well the longer than we
consolidate here or the longer than we
rent here the more liquidations that
that is going to be in this Zone
why because they are continuously trying
to induce traders to open lungs okay so
those long star opening with high
leverage they're gonna stack also the
Liquidations in this level okay so you
can see how that yellow bar gets
brighter and brighter and brighter so at
the end when they push price lower
they're gonna hit more liquidations than
they had previously so it's going to be
more efficient okay that's what I think
I think that we're gonna see soon 28 800
or 28 700 getting hit soon probably both
of them to be honest because when you
come here to uh this drop while you are
dropping here they're gonna be also
a few Longs opening okay and 28 700
should be
increasing the liquidity in my opinion
so yeah I think that that's what I'm
looking for today and next week
by looking at the chart I'm not sure
to be honest this is a personal opinion
uh not based on much okay yes uh maybe a
bit of instinct I have the feeling that
today we might see quite a boring
session
uh that's what I think okay I think that
they're gonna come to this Zone today
but again be ready just in case the
attack this soon but I think I'm not
gonna leave it for next week if I had to
to bed okay so that's pretty much
everything guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon